now to that cbs news exclusive new
evidence of a link between two 911
hijackers and a man said to be on saudi
arabia's intelligence agency payroll we
see them together in new newly released
video turned over to family members of 9
11 victims last month along with more
than 14 000 pages of documents the
evidence obtained from british
authorities raises new questions
actually renews an old one did the saudi
government assist the hijackers on 9 11.
the saudis have always denied that
explosive question senior investigative
correspondent catherine herridge has the
story
less than two weeks after 9 11 these
boxes of evidence containing personal
notes and videos were seized by british
police in birmingham england
buried inside this home video from 2000
now being seen publicly for the first
time the event is described by the 9 11
commission as a party at the san diego
apartment of two hijackers while nawafal
hosmi and khalid almidar avoted the
camera medar can be seen here in the
kitchen
their team would later commandeer flight
77 slamming it into the pentagon the
party's host a saudi national omar
al-bayoumi who british police arrested
after 9 11 and from whom they seized the
videos and documents three years after
the attack the 911 commission said there
was no credible evidence that baiumi
believed in violent extremism or
knowingly aided extremist groups though
a newly declassified fbi memo from 2017
reports byumi was on the payroll of
saudi intelligence a fact that was not
confirmed at the time of the 9 11
commission report i called him a
facilitator because he helped him out
last fall cbs news sat down with retired
fbi agents danny gonzalez and ken
williams who investigated the hijacker
support network both now work for the 9
11 families he helped him with
apartments he helped him with bank
accounts he was also an employee of the
government of saudi arabia among the
records a notepad containing a
handwritten drawing of a plain and
mathematical equation that an expert
said in a court filing could be used to
calculate the rate of dissent to a
target
bayou is believed to be living in saudi
arabia we've tried to reach him through
the saudi embassy it did not respond to
our questions but said in a statement
last year any allegation that saudi
arabia is complicit in the september
11th attacks is categorically false the
fbi declined to comment for our
reporting gail
yeah raising some very troubling
questions there thank you catherine